le pido para empezar una breve contexto
sobre el panorama de la situación
alimentaria a nivel global
sin duda los datos no son buenos lo
señalaste inicialmente estamos hablando
según los datos anuales que nosotros
divulgamos que son los de referencia
mundial más de 828 millones de personas
que pasan hambre pero el hambre no se
puede desconectar de los escenarios de
nutrición y estamos hablando de más de
dos mil doscientos millones de personas
que no se nutren bien en un cuadro
general afectado por el covid por la
guerra pero sobre todo por la
transformación de los del cambio
climático y ahora pasaremos a analizar
estas causas que usted señalaba Pero le
pido también
la situación en América Latina porque
ustedes por ejemplo advierten del riesgo
en Centroamérica
sin duda si hablamos de números de
América Latina y el Caribe estamos
hablando de 56 millones de personas que
se encuentran en situación de hambre más
de 130 millones mínimamente que no se
alimentan bien son datos graves Porque
si pensamos Cómo era el escenario previo
al covid del 2019 entre el período
previo al covid y el periodo de esta
fase del 2021
aumentó en un 30% son números realmente
muy altos y si nosotros hablamos de
escenarios de crisis dramática tú lo has
señalado inicialmente Haití es el
momento más dramático que existe en
América Latina y el Caribe en el cual te
debemos concentrar mucho más esfuerzo de
lo que estamos haciendo actualmente y
Mario como usted respondía la primera
pregunta los medios de comunicación nos
hemos centrado mucho en los efectos de
la guerra en Ucrania sobre el sistema
mundial de alimentos pero le preguntó
que otros factores afec a las
situaciones de inseguridad alimentaria
en el mundo yo creo que hay una
combinación de cuatro aspectos que son
Realmente explosivos primero el tema del
hambre no es un momento es un tema que
ha venido ahora viene hace muchísimos
años con escenario de desbalance y
desequilibrio socioeconómico América
Latina y el Caribe es una de las
regiones más desequilibradas desde el
punto de vista del equilibrio y los
balances socioeconómico pero después
tuvimos el escenario del covid y todos
los efectos que estamos viviendo ahora
en lo que podríamos Llamar la fase de
Pero además hemos tenido unos efectos de
la guerra
en Ucrania que en nuestros países
afectan en la importación de
fertilizantes en la importación de
cereales de manera muy severa y
naturalmente ahora estamos y estuvimos
estamos y sin duda que está impactando
cada vez más los fenómenos climáticos
entre sequía inundaciones y nuevos
fenómeno que estamos previendo que puede
llegar sobre todo hacia el escenario
centroamericano y caribeño que es el
nuevo fenómeno del niño por lo tanto
Estos factores
conjugados son explosivos y impensables
que se combinaran todos juntos en esta
fase